STARTED IT ALL.
GREAT TO SEE YOU TONIGHT.
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: SO WE OPENED THE SHOW
TELLING YOU ABOUT THE COMEDIAN
JOSH DENNY, SILENCED AS A
COMEDIAN BECAUSE HE HAS PRO-LIFE
VIEWS.
HE'S NOT THE ONLY ONE, THOUGH.
JOHN GIBSON WAS THE CEO OF
TRIPWIRE, A VIDEO GAME COMPANY.
LAST YEAR HE TWEETED THIS, AND
THIS IS THE WHOLE TWEET.
QUOTE, PROUD OF THE U.S. SUPREME
COURT AFFIRMING THAT TEXAS LAW
BANNING ABORTION FOR BABIES WITH
A HEARTBEAT.
AS AN ENTERTAINER I DON'T GET
POLITICAL OFTEN, YET WITH SO
MANY VOCAL PEERS ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE ISSUE I FELT IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO GO ON THE RECORD
ACE PRO-LIFE GAME DEVELOPER."
THAT WAS IT.
HE DIDN'T ATTACK ANYONE, JUST
SAID WHAT HE BELIEVED.
FOR TWEETING THAT, HE LOST HIS
JOB.
THE COMPANY THAT HE STARTED, WAS
MAJORITY OWNER OF, OR HAD THE
LARGEST OWNERSHIP STAKE IN, AND
THEN THE MEDIA DECIDED TO
DESTROY HIM PERSONALLY.
UNBELIEVABLE EXPERIENCE.
WE SPOKE TO HIM ABOUT IT.
HERE'S PART OF THE CONVERSATION.
>> I CALL IT SOCIAL TERRORISM.
>> YES.
>> IT IS AN EFFORT TO USE FEAR
AND INTIMIDATION TO CAUSE PEOPLE
TO CHANGE -- EITHER -- EITHER
HIDE OR PRETEND THAT THEY'RE NOT
TO WHAT THEY ARE REALLY SO THEY
CAN KEEP THEIR JOBS, THEY CAN
KEEP THEIR STATUS, AND I JUST
THINK THAT'S -- THAT'S JUST A
TERRIBLE THING FOR THE WORLD.
>> Tucker: WELL, IT'S PRIMA
FACIA EVIL FOR ONE THING.
TERRORISM IS ALWAYS WRONG.
YOU KNOW, EVERYTHING SHOULD BE
VOLUNTARY.
I MEAN, YOU CAN'T FORCE PEOPLE
TO BELIEVE SOMETHING.
THAT'S CRAZY.
YOU KNOW, THAT'S EIGHTH CENTURY
ISLAM, BEING BEHEADED OR
SOMETHING.
THERE WAS NOT ONE PERSON -- BY
THE WAY, I WROTE DOWN SOCIAL
TERRORISM, BECAUSE I'M STEALING
THAT.
I'M NOT GIVING YOU CREDIT.
SORRY.
IT'S SUCH A PRECISE PHRASE
VERSUS COUNTER CULTURE, WHICH IS
PATHETIC AND WEAK, AND DOES NOT
DESCRIBE THE PHENOMENON.
NOT ONE PERSON IN YOUR WORLD
STOOD UP AND SAID WE CANNOT
CRUSH THIS MAN BECAUSE HE HAS A
DIFFERENT VIEW?
>> THERE WAS -- UMM, THERE WAS
ONE PERSON, WITHIN THE COMPANY,
THAT -- UMM, UMM, A LADY THAT
WAS RESISTANT TO WHAT THEY WERE
DOING TO ME.
>> Tucker: GOOD FOR HER.
>> UMM, AND SHE WAS FAIRLY
SENIOR.
UMM, AND I REALLY APPRECIATED
HER, YOU KNOW, SORT OF STANDING
UP AND PUSHING BACK.
BUT IT WAS -- IT WAS -- IT WAS
DIFFICULT FOR HER, TOO.
I MEAN, SHE WAS OUTNUMBERED.
UMM, AND -- BUT ALSO IN THE
POSITION SHE WAS IN, SHE WAS
HAVING TO DEAL WITH A LOT OF THE
FALLOUT, AND THAT'S -- THAT'S
HOW THIS SOCIAL TERRORISM WORKS,
IS YOU MAKE PEOPLE SCARED.
YOU MAKE THEIR JOBS MORE
DIFFICULT.
YOU MAKE THEM WORRY THAT PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO LEAVE THE COMPANY
IF THEY DON'T, YOU KNOW, THROW
THE PERSON WHO -- WHO DISAGREED
WITH IN AS POLITICAL POSITIONS
OUT OF THE BOAT.
AND, UMM, SO SHE REALLY COULDN'T
OVERCOME THE WAVE OF SENTIMENT
OF THE OTHER FOLKS.
THEN THE PEOPLE THAT -- THAT --
THE OTHER PEOPLE THAT AGREED,
THEY'RE AFRAID TO SPEAK UP.
THEY DON'T WANT TO BE NEXT.
UMM, I HAD ONE OF THE OWNER OWE
OTHER OWNERS OF THE COMPANY
POLITICALLY WERE VERY, VERY,
UMM, WERE VERY ALIGNED.
HE THINKS CANCEL CULTURE IS BAD.
HE THINKS ABORTION IS BAD.
UMM, AND HE SAID, UMM, YEAH, I
DON'T WANT TO BE CANCELED NEXT.
>> Tucker: HOW HEARTBREAKING WAS
THAT?
I MEAN, THESE ARE YOUR FRIENDS.
YOU CREATED THE COMPANY WITH
THEM.
YOU WORKED WITH THEM FOR 20
YEARS.
TO SEE THEM PARTICIPATE IN THIS
MUST HAVE DESTROYED YOU.
>> TUCKER, WORDS -- WORDS CAN
HARDLY CONVEY, UMM, HOW CRUSHED
I WAS.
UMM, YOU -- EVERYONE THAT WORKS
PUTS A LITTLE BIT OF THEMSELVES
INTO SOMETHING, OR MAYBE A LOT.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
>> WHEN YOU'RE DOING -- WHEN
YOU'RE SOMETHING THAT -- LIKE
THIS, A PASSION, SOMETHING YOU
USED TO DO FOR FREE, AND YOU
JUST ABSOLUTELY LOVE IT, AND
IT'S -- YOU SPENT 20 YEARS, 25
YEARS OF YOUR LIFE, CRAFTING THE
SKILL SET, AND YOU'RE AT THE TOP
OF YOUR GAME, AND YOU LOVE WHAT
YOU DO EVERY DAY, JUST LOVE
COMING INTO WORK, AND MAKING
PEOPLE HAPPY.
AND WE -- WE WERE MAKING, SURE,
MILLIONS OF FANS HAPPY, BUT ALSO
THE COMPANY WOULD TAKE 10% OF
OUR PROFITS AND DIVIDE IT UP
AMONGST THE EMPLOYEES.
THERE WAS A LOT OF PROFIT.
PEOPLE WERE GOING OUT AND BUYING
CARS AND HOUSES.
I WOULD SEE PEOPLE COMING INTO
WORK, SMILING AND HAPPY.
I JUST LOVED HAVING A JOB WHERE
I GOT TO MAKE, NOT JUST THE
PUBLIC HAPPY, BUT THE EMPLOYEES
HAPPY.
AND TO HAVE THAT ALL DESTROYED,
UMM, TO FEEL LIKE -- WELL, I
SHARED SOMETHING WITH MY WIFE.
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT I SAID TO
HER.
I SAID -- I SAID I JUST WANT TO
DIE, YOU KNOW, BECAUSE I DON'T
WANT TO LIVE -- I DON'T WANT TO
LIVE IN A WORLD THAT'S THIS
UNJUST.
>> Tucker: I AGREE.
>> AND YEAH.
YEAH, I GOT DEPRESSED.
I GOT, OF COURSE, ANGRY,
SUICIDAL.
UMM, NOT WANTING TO LEAVE THE
HOUSE.
UMM -- YEAH, IT DESTROYED ME.
AND I HAVE LIVED THROUGH 13
MONTHS OF HELL.
>> Tucker: THE ENTIRE EPISODE
WILL BE AVAILA